nuevos hallazgos sobre omicron aunque
los resultados son preliminares la
agencia de seguridad sanitaria del reino
unido asegura que la efectividad de las
vacunas contra la variante disminuye si
sólo se cuenta con dos dosis la
efectividad que más se vio afectada fue
la de los fármacos de facer y
astrazéneca
esto significa que las personas que han
recibido dos dosis hace más de tres
meses tienen probabilidades de contraer
el virus y transmitirlo el estudio
comparó 581 casos confirmados de omicron
con miles de delta sin embargo quienes
recibieron la tercera dosis de fisher
lograron un 75 por ciento de protección
contra la enfermedad sintomática y en
los que recibieron a extras zénica la
respuesta fue del 70% el aumento de
casos de la variante omicron junto con
los nuevos datos de hoy deberían ser una
llamada de atención para aquellos que
aún no han recibido su refuerzo o de
hecho ninguna vacuna los datos se
conocen cuando el reino unido-
experimenta un aumento exponencial de
casos que se estarían duplicando cada 2
o 3 días otros países europeos también
se han visto golpeados con fuerza en
alemania las nuevas llegaron a más de
61.000 el número de muertes llegó a los
438 un número que no se veía desde
febrero en este hospital de berlín las
uci están al borde del colapso para
contrarrestar la crisis el gobierno
exigirá a partir de marzo que todos los
trabajadores de la salud estén vacunados
en marsella en francia que enfrenta a la
quinta ola de infecciones los médicos de
la uci luchan por los enfermos del virus
aunque el impacto se ha reducido en
comparación con otras olas el país
cuenta ya casi con 2500 personas en
unidades de cuidado intensivo